avec 36 degrés à l'ombre les baigneurs
cherche la fraîcheur dans l'eau sur les
bords du doubs la zone est pourtant
interdite à la baignade
certains endroits sous profond avec du
courant on reste plutôt de ce côté là ce
que de l'autre côté il ya beaucoup de
courant donc tout à l'heure
mon copain s'est laissé surprendre donc
on reste plutôt de ce côté week-end
petit en plus michel a grandi ici
il a vu douze personnes se noyait dans
ses eaux c'est que le doubs les pros
dangereux voilà c'est pour ça que je
viens porte
moi j'ai dû quatre petits-enfants ils
viennent pas là il est mieux aller dans
une autre endroit que c'est sécurisé
hier encore un homme de 39 ans a perdu
la vie sur cette zone
victime d'un malaise dans ce service des
urgences les arrivées liés à la canicule
sont nombreuses
il faut faire attention aux gros
changements de température si on passe
d'une zone très exposé au soleil on a eu
très très chaud et qu'on va dans une
zone du coup froide qui est dans une eau
plus froides les changements thermique
rapides peuvent induire des problèmes et
des gens qui ont eu le fond des
problèmes cardiaques il ya des gens qui
font bouillir au cul sion sert le chox
du juste aux changements de température
six personnes sont aperçoit il faut
absolument que quelqu'un qui lui portent
sur éviter les heures les plus chaudes
entré dans l'eau progressivement
s'hydrater des consignes de bon sens
à ne pas oublier pour se rafraîchir la
nuque se mouiller les bras le bas du
ventre faut toujours se mouiller
rafraîchir le corps avant la journée
d'hier a été dramatique
cinq personnes sont mortes noyées en
france
prudence donc et préférez les zones de
baignade surveillées pour vous prélasser
en sécurité